各位你的工作狀態是不是每天在Gmail Google sheet
Google doc之間跳來跳去
手速快到連我媽都認為我在打電動
但現在這一切通通自動化了 看到這張圖沒有
我們只要動動嘴巴
Google Opal就幫我生出一個專屬的小助理 今天這集不講虛的
直接教你怎麽樣用Opal讓工作自己動起來
嗨各位又是我AJ
大家在講Agent
講代理人
但是很多人一聽到寫程式這件事情就想說啊好了好了好了算了
太難太難了
沒事Google聽到我們懶人的心聲了
這個Google Opal簡單來說就是AI界的樂高
你不用寫半行程序碼
只要用白話文描述你的邏輯
它就會自動幫你把AI模組
外部工具 串在一起
今天我們就要快速的帶你了解Google Opal這個自動化工具
首先我們來到我們熟悉的Google首頁 你只要直接搜尋Opal
Google你就會找到這個Google Opal experiment
點進來之後呢 你就會看到Google OpalO里面有這些哦
各種各式各樣的這些自動化流程 那比如說我們選這個blog post writer
然後你就點進去
他里面其實也已經有幫你建制好的這些相關的這些工作流程
那我們就只要點選開始
好比如說我們問 過年紅包包多少
請用繁體中文輸出
那這邊你會看到他開始每一個節點在那邊轉轉轉
然後代表它正在工作
如果你是細節控的話 你可以點一下這個console你就會看到他正在調用了
German 2.5 Flash
然後create plan 好做完之後他才會開始寫outline
然後開始會同步的去create 部落格的這個banner image
然後最終幫你整合變成一篇部落格文章
然後最終顯示出來
再來就是因為這個介面現在還是英文的
他還是一個實驗中的方案
賬號是小老鼠gmailo.com的賬號 你才能夠使用這個功能
這個功能一旦成熟了
他也會把它整合到我們的Google workspace
所以你看過年紅包包多少
從古至今文化行情禁忌一次搞定
那出來這個結果
我想要全部看他 我只要選APP這個模式
我就會看到這個APP他現在目前跑出來這個成果
所以你可以直接share output
他就會直接好幫你把這個結果丟到你的Google雲端硬碟里面
然後就可以直接獲得一個可以被分享的這個URL
你就可以把這個連結 傳出去給你的同事朋友
他就可以直接看到你剛剛生成出來的這樣那個內容
你也可以直接把這個網頁下載下來
他就會給你一個html的這個檔案
然後你就可以直接在你的電腦里面去做這樣的一個後續的這個編輯調整
或是你要把它塞到你們公司的那些網站 或者是部落格平台啊
或者是官網公告等等這些東西
那你也可以看到這一次出來的這個圖片里面
這個中文字看起來還是有些問題
很明顯就是他目前只調用了Nano Banana模型
而不是調用最新的Nano Banana Pro模型
但這個我覺得也是時間的問題 那但是這時候你一定會想說哎不對啊
那如果我要做的事情在這里面沒有怎麽辦
那你有兩個地方你可以做 第一個你可以直接在Opal的網頁里面按create new
你就可以去在這個地方手動的去拉一些節點出來
然後把這些節點連在一起
但是 這太難了
所以我們今天要教各位一個更簡單的做法
就是我們可以在下面直接用自然語言的方式
要求他去幫我把這些節點自動做出來
比如說製作一個周末活動調查高手我輸入城市名稱
可以幫我調查該城市最近一週有什麽公開活動
市集或展覽可以前往 然後我就直接送出
這時候Gemini他會去分析你的需求
然後他會自動的去調用上面的那些模組自動幫你把那些模組做起來
自己幫你連起來 做出來的成果不如你的想象跟預期
那這時候你一樣是用提示詞的方式去要求他去做這樣的一個修正
好你看這都做好了 他就幫我做了一個三個節點然後就可以直接start
然後我們就可以說我要找台北 用繁體中文輸出
未來七天台北的活動出來
那這時候 除了你可以在Opal.Google這個網頁上面之外呢
最近Opal還出現在另外一個新的地方Gemini的網頁版
Google首頁然後右上角這邊 就可以看到這個Gemini的這個雙子星
點進去Gemini網頁版里面 展開選單往上拉在GEM里面
你看到我現在Google lab推出全新的卷體驗
他其實把Opal整合在這個地方了
你一樣可以在這個地方 看到你原本的那些GEM
那我們這邊 選一個別的 比如說什麽sticker Generator
那點進去之後 他會幫你有一些他已經預先建立好了這個工作流程
就可以根據你的需求來去create那個sticker
如果這個Generator 你想要加入一些你自己的風格一些想法
這個人家已經做好的這個Opal的這個模組你可以直接點這個叫做Remix
就可以自己根據你的需求比如說 在貼紙的設計
當中加入台灣的元素
但是 這個step里面的東西你不可以直接改
你要去prompt你的Gemini 然後讓Gemini自己去改上面的這些step
好所以你可以去看那個step里面他改的什麽東西
或者是你看那些東西之後你覺得好像還漏了什麽東西
你就可以直接用Prompt的方式來去要求Gemini
去幫助你改的這個自動化這個工作流程
好那最後跟各位分享幾個我們在測試跟操作的時候所歸納出來的一些
小的撇步跟心得
第一個就是如果他跑出來這個結果
要求他改半天還是改不出你想要的那個結果
這時候你可以點選這邊的節點
比如說我覺得他那個出來的圖片 細部的這些提示詞覺得怪怪的
那我們就可以點這個節點
然後他就會進入這個step的模式 你就可以在這個地方調整
比如說他用哪一個模型
或者是他這邊會有一個他真實的這些提示詞
那這個時候呢你可以按這個魔術棒
你可以直接在這個節點內的Prompt直接要求AI去幫你提示詞調整
或者是你就直接在這個地方 打你要調整的提示詞 第二件事情
你就會想說那這個Opal他到底可以做到什麽事情啊
那我們也幫你整理過 第一個他可以做網路搜尋
那第二個他可以做Google的這個事實查核 知識圖譜
他去串Google搜尋的這些資料庫
第三個它就是圖片生成
第四個它可以做影片生成 所以你也可以試試看要求他去做影片
那當然文字生成跟推理這沒有問題
再來就是大家很常用的叫做deep research深度研究
然後你也可以去做Google map的地圖搜尋
或者是當前的一些天氣跟時間有關的一些活動
比如說我們像我們剛剛去找說
那個台北這個禮拜未來7天有什麽樣的一個活動
那再來你也可以上傳一些檔案給他做一個參考
然後另外
你可以直接要求他把輸出的結果丟到比如說像Google試算表 Google sheet里面
好那還有就是輸入成動態網頁
就是各位剛剛看到那個Blog那個文章就是動態網頁
那接下來還有幾個功能
比如說他可以作為Python的執行節點
我覺得這個東西就有點像是Chat GPT的那個CO interpreter
他就會去生成Python的程式碼
然後就幫你執行 你給他的資料
然後幫你去做分析然後去做後續一些繪圖啦
或者是去跑一些相關的資料出來
再來一次他跟Google workspace會去做一些深度的整合
那官方是說他會跟Gmail Google drive Google Calendar等等的這些
Google體系的相關的這些工具去做一些聯動
那再來你也可以去做一些就是比較複雜的程式工作
比如說你可以去拔一些迴圈的概念
這些概念把它加到你的工作流程當中哦
然後或者是你可以去加上一些覆雜的條件分支
去要求這個Google Opal來去自動幫你整理你的整個工作流程
好以上就是我們今天這集Google Opal的一個非常非常簡單快速的一個分享
那如果你喜歡這些影片的話歡迎你訂閱
或是你可以把你在Opal上面做出來這些有趣的這些應用
在影片下面的留言里面
跟這些網友們來去做一些分享
那接著影片就到這個地方 拜拜